may the worst man die
electric skateboard jousting the spring
festival if you've been watching the
previous videos
we've had a tournament of champions
which has come down
to four champions myself nick carmichael
and nico
all competing for the right to represent
one brand and to give away
a free subscription to that brand for
the rest of 2019 that king sam will
determine
two semi-final rounds the winners
semi-final rounds will go to fight in a
final round
and the final round will not end until
one of the knights is dead
that's right so even if you fall off
your horse you can still pick up a sword
and keep fighting oh sister two my
bloodline shall win my mother
and my uncle made me it's more like a
family
family uh yes is a
posture the first
combatant he's red your highness
and his opponent will be
[Music]
this isn't a neck or chief what is that
let's just say a holy relic
no this is actually our next limited
edition sale
it's incredible to me just for the
spring tournament of champions
i think it's so holy that there's only
500 of these that exist
on earth if you like this snag one today
at quarterdigital.store
and his opponent
[Music]
the dark blue knight lord patreon
hey how dare you smack me with your
gloves how dare you david for the save
it for the tournament save it for the
time
for the tournament each jousting round
will be a best of three if you knock
your opponent off twice
you win we had a bunch of bamboo left
over from the prim tech shoot so we took
12 foot pieces
of bamboo put some boxing gloves around
the end of them and bam
[Music]
all right ready and
three two one
i said
you guys don't need to go slow just
because we're recording slow-mo
[Applause]
i'm getting better every time
come here winner it's never easy letting
down your friends
he's terrifying it's like an army with
spears
my strategy is believing myself and have
faith in what life has given me
something good momentum no practice
rounds i'm being serious
you will be judged on the merit of your
joust
may the worst man die go
[Music]
nico still on what an impact
play audible so if niko wins this next
round he is
the uh semi champion may the worst man
die
that was intense
[Applause]
oh man you took his helmet off dude he
didn't know what hit him
yeah yeah your nose is it's bleeding a
bit it's just a flashlight
this is actually going to decide who
wins they're finally tied back up
i want to say one of these men died
[Music]
club
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the irony taste of blood in my mouth
it's just enraged me even more
to face off against certain nick the
younger he's about to come to sir nick
the underground so nico's stance is
pretty
it's pretty unstoppable right now it's a
very very solid stance so i think i'm
going to take a note out of his book and
try to do the double knee plant
um
this is the final joust
the last man standing will be the one
who wins ready
[Music]
oh
champion
you can still pick up a sword and keep
[Music]
fighting
[Applause]
[Music]
up but by technically down right that
means kill him down just kill him
ah that's how it was the on in the olden
days down was uh actually killing you
rightfully won
the joust and the duel so you are the
champion
yes dude do i get hanging chains
as many as you want endless big chain
will hook you up
i will choose one lucky person to get a
year of expressvpn
free before we find out who the winner
is of this expressvpn reward with nick i
wanted to take a moment and tell you
guys about
our brand new shirts that's right we
only made 500 of these that's 500
and they're going and they're on sale
right now at corridor digital dot store
in fact by the time you get there
there's certainly going to be less than
500 so
head on over there if you like it show
your friends how much you love
d d or just this great design and
remember we had this thing created
because the spring festival was coming
up and we wanted to do something cool
something special
uh to commemorate and mark that moment
if you guys like what we do on this
channel
definitely consider supporting us by
picking up a t-shirt
um because the money goes right back
into these videos so
nico we're waiting for them to go to the
store there's only 500 of these
will probably sell out the first few
days they always do especially if you
have like a
average size like medium right you want
it go now
wait another five seconds
i think the doorbell okay every minute
now let's tell them let's tell them all
right okay
all right so we're gonna go through the
comments here we're gonna see
which comment really captures the spirit
of the spring festival you had to have
expressvpn as a service or
gotten it because of this video and made
a comment in this video we're gonna be
looking for somebody that says that in
the comments
all right so we're getting a lot of road
worker videos obviously because our
comments
on the yeah pothole warfare like to cook
soup in potholes
healthy i mean that's it's not healthy
yeah i just want to say that your ads
are i think okay i love free express vbn
but it's t
okay as a i i a european really need
vpn for my memes now that article 13 has
been approved
that kind of hits me right here we go
here's one guy
that's good i signed up to expressvpn
because of this video
okay another okay i want to use express
i want to use he's not using
here's another one i actually use
especially if you're in china
expressvpn for life yo there was no
statement of i have the service
i use it so i'm disqualified sorry oh
okay i actually use expressvpn in china
so i can play games and use discord it's
great and all has only stopped working a
few times over a year during large vpn
crackdowns
i think this guy might please give me
expressvpn i have subscribed
that doesn't cut it but thank you for
your subscription um a lot of people are
just asking for the vpn but not stating
that they have it
alright all right so there's i use
expressvpn i signed up to expressvpn
because of this video and i use
expressvpn in china and expressvpn for
life
yo so who's the best we're going to go
with hulu loose labs
from china may your memes and discord
be uninterrupted from now on at least
for the end of the year because
buddy you got expressvpn all year long
hulu's lab son oh yeah and uh
in case you've forgotten you should uh
turn on the notifications
and subscribe because most of you aren't
even subscribed and that's sad